what's going on there reject nation
we're gonna watch today umbrella academy
season three episode eight last one was
a fantastic episode loved
it's card up above us if you haven't
seen that one yet guys uh leave a like
that'd be so so appreciated also
subscribe and click that notification
bell get notified when a reaction for
the next umbrella is up here on the
channel full length watch long as we
sync up the time code are available for
super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page thank you all for joining us for
umbrella academy alone means a lot to
cover specific shows we're at the same
tier you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs included we
are developing a website by the way keep
forgetting to mention that to make it
easier to navigate our patreon been a
few months we've been at it lastly the
prepper boys thank you for sending down
these highlights and girl actually i
noticed you thank you let's get to it
oh okay 1918.
when graves was just an explorer
hargrave origins
[Music]
what
i don't know what that means but these
plans is bizarre
i said i don't understand these plans i
don't understand you
yeah i wonder how old hargraves actually
is like thousands of years old oh no
stupid old
that's a great shot
the hotel oblivion
oh my god he built it
he built it
whoa
he built the hotel around the the portal
oh shoot
now that's a reveal yeah it is
finally get some goddamn answers about
this place
[Music]
so this is 1918 does that mean our
hargraves did this too probably right
yeah yeah okay i want them all dead okay
oh okay
one remained alive back in the flash
very good very good
[Music]
all dead
all dead
all dead
all of them are dead and now you are too
that buffalo turn its head whoa what
though
the cockroaches
oh
ah i see it
yep
i see it too
[Laughter]
took me a second but i saw it
that looks like a building in l.a has
anyone seen klaus
or dad they'll be here
really did they hit traffic
[Laughter]
i got a better one of course you did we
go the large hard-on particle
accelerator you guys do some science and
we launch the cougar blitz into outer
space
it's had run not hard on ya [ __ ]
look when i went to the commission i had
a conversation with my hundred-year-old
self
and my last words were don't save the
world
don't save the world don't save the
world don't save the world save the
universe your big plan is
no plan look maybe this is just what the
universe needs
see what's on the other side what if
it's
nothing
then it's been nice knowing you guys go
through the door thingy whatever's on
your bucket list i recommend you do that
now
i bet all of you guys could stop what's
inside the door
if you work together
we've uh got a little announcement to
make
we're engaged
[Laughter]
yeah look we realized the timing is less
than ideal but obviously it's now or
never am i right five don't drag me into
this
if you would join us in the banquet hall
at 6 00 p.m for a celebration of our
love and
the official union of what's left of our
two great families
you still here
it's been quite some time you two know
each other of course we do i own this
hotel where are the children they're
upstairs sir very good ready my sweet mr
order right away sir come on then my boy
did you just say you own this hotel we
don't have time to discuss the finer
points of real estate
[Laughter]
i'm just saying try not to be overly
you okay
just follow my lead klaus
i like this hard graves you two are
hanging now yeah we laughed we cried we
played in traffic and long story short
i'm immortal now
[Laughter]
that was the most the alarm thing i've
ever seen it's my friend you guys luther
and i are getting married
all of space and time is collapsing and
you lot are planning yeah and uh the
thing is space is limited so it's kind
of a per-plate situation
[Laughter]
you took him off his meds what were you
thinking clearly he's the only one doing
any thinking at all all of you could
learn a thing or two from this
impressive young man
your training is to resume post taste
we're running out of time and we still
have a mission to complete i'm ready
let's do this you just want daddy's
approval nobody wants you here dad
you should leave hey you don't speak for
all of us big guy feel free to join him
so this is what it's come to
insurrection
that's not the kind of erection
it's totally last minute and i mean the
whole thing is last minute but what is
it
will you be my best man
i would love to
are you still playing hard to get quiet
i'm brainstorming
the boys are waiting downstairs before
the wedding i'm not going to that
wedding like hell you're not you're my
plus one get dressed i'm not going
we got a kid to take care of all right i
don't know that i'm the one incubating
that little thing i don't get why you're
not fighting harder for this not all
fights are worth fighting for the egg
odds are we don't survive this i'll take
those off if it means i get to spend it
with you and the baby
oh
this is so touching happened to mr lone
wolf doesn't need anybody he met a crazy
lady oh
you guys are gonna kill each other
you can spend tonight fighting your
bloody apocalypse or being with me
don't do that
you can't have both
don't make him make that choice please
let him take a chance at surviving come
on
i choose you
so we're just over the death of stanley
[ __ ] that kid was a nurse
but they'll never improve their
capabilities if they don't have an acute
understanding of how incredibly
incompetent and deeply disappointing
they are
jay why don't we try a little small talk
before we go
you know full stalling hey
i want you
to say
something nice to me i dare you
go for it
you have a well-proportioned forehead
[Laughter]
you're considerate yet easily excitable
great
it's actually not bad i'm surprised you
didn't invite daddy dearest to come join
us oh come on he's such a kind and
thoughtful soul he's not like our
hargreaves oh contraire nothing i can
see total eclipse
this is so sweet
finally come to a decision what's it
gonna be maestro it's gonna be a duet my
friend oh yay
this is gonna be good no karaoke is good
that's the point
[Laughter]
talk to allison
no come on victor if there's anything on
your bucket let's do it now why does it
have to be on my list because she's
always been good to you
better than the rest of us
that is true she would feel the most
betrayed
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hmm oh ben wasn't invited he has no one
they're a real family they don't exist
to sell action figures and tote bags we
were more than that were we why is it so
important for you to be a sparrow
hmm
because i have nothing else
a real ben scene you still got that
stick bro you can be friends with that
stick in your ass
get along for a couple of hours you can
consider that my wedding gift well he
started it so literally
so ugly
[Laughter]
all right guys
we're gathered here today
for a good time not a long time so let's
have a good time huh
[Laughter]
and amen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
banging amen to be your lady
yeah she's beautiful
slowed do you promise to love
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
i pronounce you married as [ __ ]
yeah married as [ __ ] baby
[Music]
it's five dollars for a four by five
eight if you want two of them
the cockroach is big
it's so good is that yeah
let me try yours
but with the sauce my lamb yeah
[Music]
hey the two unlikable people would you
look at that no no no no about dad no no
no no no no no no no no no no
baby baby he's a changed man
you know he helped me to conquer my
childhood fears we played catch together
boys
with that yeah we call it bus ball
that's kind of our thing
[Laughter]
later
i'm here to show my support
oh my god even the music stopped who
invited just sit here and suffer i can't
even get invited to a bachelor party and
he's invited to this wedding wow you
really can't relax can you now we're all
here
chill
i really like this episode it's
pretty great lately
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god is alison going to make the
initiative it's making me sad hmm you're
introducing me no no
no i'm not oh go
oh they haven't met
wow i realized that until this moment
spittlefield clothes white chapel you
must know the cat in custard right next
to the fox and hounds best chippy in
east london oh i wouldn't murder for a
spot of mushy peas right about now
so
how did you end up with this one well we
met in a mental hospital i have no doubt
sandwich is sort of a picnic but he'll
do
indy
[Music]
i reggie diego for him huh
that's quite the specimen
well done i thought
oh
oh
that really warmed my heart oh you made
a superb father oh
he knows
man do i have a mission for you
oh jesus you couldn't even invite me
to your stupid bachelor party oh
have we finally flecked off bad penny's
hard candy shell why don't you like me
because you're a huge puckering [ __ ]
nobody's polishing their boots or
pressing their tights
we're a complete and total [ __ ] show he
get it and our been my bed
was just that kind of disaster and it
made it ridiculously easy to love
god klaus is definitely my favorite all
you said you ever wanted was for us to
be close and we finally got there and
you
[ __ ] it up is this really how you want
to end things don't worry
i'll sleep fine tonight
the sun rises over a lily's field god
she's unbearable
jesus christ good acting
this one is for all the party people in
the place
oh
damn
[Music]
ben's dancing
oh he is dancing would you look at that
dad recited a weirdly moving death
pokemon
no that's not bad for hargreave family
wedding
[Music]
that's more like
yeah it is oh no no no no no no no no
klaus why are you bringing ben here you
gotta hear me out before i hear him out
the [ __ ] he's gone now klaus what are
you talking about and the man that
stands in front of you
is
new new ben
[Laughter]
because it's my wedding day man come on
he can stay
hey big guy
awfully nice of you yeah you're welcome
how are they gonna save the world this
[ __ ] up
i got 48 hours they'll be fine they'll
be hungover as hell but they'll be fine
at least they get to enjoy the
apocalypse this is true
i would have thought death would be so
beautiful
everybody coming together when it really
matters
except for allison
real family
sloan you're the new allison
actually
i think i'm hungry see you guys i'm
gonna hit the buffet
you see
it'd be fun to wait
there is no time
i can't do this without you
do we have a deal
oh my god it's older him isn't it
shoots who was that
i don't know maybe that's been i don't
know
i thought it was older five
or
older five come to play none of the
symptoms
started to affect
him i don't know
what's happening
somebody emotionally being a dick here
[Laughter]
you're being a five
seriously man you're being a whole
allison right now um what'd you think we
can't talk for too long got too much to
cover right now it wasn't the most
action-packed episode but you know what
that's okay i feel like we spent enough
time with these characters
within the drama
if you let me get there
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
no i think uh it was
great i thought it was a great episode
uh we've spent so much time with these
characters in this season and this
journey we've had watched in the last
eight episodes that i feel like this
wedding episode was really earned and it
was very sincere and it's very sweet
watching all these characters come
together and finally feel like a family
at a wedding it felt like even with all
the absurdity of
the different dynamics within these
characters that it felt very
authentic and very sweet and even as
cynical as i am
being not on board with them
getting together so soon getting married
even i have to say that i was very
warmed and touched by this wedding and i
believed it you made me believe in love
greg love island
season one and two on netflix this is
blind brazil
yeah man i think uh yeah everyone's
coming around i even liked ben this
episode you know from
being the dick to be like trying to turn
into leaf you know like
klaus you know him and klaus have always
had a strong bond so it makes sense for
klaus to be the one that kind of bring
the light to him which i really enjoyed
uh i really want allison turn around i
really liked her in the other seasons
and she's just kind of the worst um
actress is doing great actress is
killing it that's how you know cause
i really don't like her but you know
that's the point you're not supposed to
be on board with her which
i understand
it's still frustrating to watch but i
understand it yeah i i think um i mean i
feel like some people might be on board
with what allison's doing there's always
those people that's true
and we'll say it'll be like one of the
top comments and then like 180 people
are voting and like there are the people
on board
[Music]
um
yeah i mean because i think especially
because victor didn't
intend for any of this to happen and
like no one's given victor
it seems like no one's even giving
victor the
benefit of the doubt of the fact that
like
harlan was a little boy in the last time
you know any of you saw harlan right and
instilled the powers in him
unintentionally just trying to save him
and then he didn't intend any of this it
was all and it was all a giant accident
like he was like i'm gonna murder people
you know so that's why it would be one
thing if harlan was like
had a
you know uh uh some type of vendetta and
was doing something evil but he wasn't
and it was it was an accident even saved
them at one point so
um yeah you know i think it's really i
think it is messed up and like she lied
for like a day you know
it was like a day and a half it wasn't
that long and you know it's like and
then uh he lied god damn it victor
vic
i'm gonna nail this i'm sorry you spent
the whole season's calling
ellie h the different pronoun okay i'm
gonna get it down but yeah with um with
uh
with that with victor i i do i did like
you know the scene where he confronts
allison that was a very emotional scene
and
uh the the acting all around but others
like this whole
bittersweet melancholic type of episode
uh it was very touching it was very warm
like you said
and you know it it did feel like yeah i
mean you can't take the words out of my
mouth this did feel like a true family
episode of them that that's not about
them coming together
in the other seasons uh not that it's
necessarily always sometimes that vibe
of like okay we gotta save the day let's
call them together you know and they
don't come together because of that they
they come together to celebrate
something uh in in the midst of
something horrendous happening outside
and finding the beauty in the last of
your days
so i did think it was like very
beautiful and uh with this really dark
backdrop to it the whole time
but i quite enjoyed it i think these
last two episodes have been phenomenal
i've really really
found them very touching and great and
like the last one was very exciting and
this one was
much more heartfelt but you know it it
again i know i kind of said this a
couple episodes ago of how this season
feels the most like a play more than the
other ones and then you get an episode
like this that's mainly in a banquet
hall or uh wedding venue where the hell
they are you know and and i thought that
was just so so sweet and touching and
the visuals are you know it's like
you're looking at the apocalypse and
there's something beautiful to behold
about that where normally the apocalypse
for them is the thing that's going to
happen in like one day you know
and here it's been this slow progression
that's been happening and i mean not not
slow but they get to kind of like sit
back and kind of witness it you know
as opposed to it's all going to happen
in one day so they got to kind of take
this and
it does touch and hard graves too um
you know i i believe he is trying his
best i don't know if he's got her eyes
excuse me go back and forth
so i'm like like he's really trying but
is he really trying to manipulate him
and get them what he wants them to do
you know
but that speech is really
um
really really really really great great
stuff great stuff
great stuff all around
uh yeah man i think uh i am i am also
rooting for hargraves to be good but
also suspicious kind of like how you
were saying and yeah there is the the
beauty in the face of death i think that
really made this a really warm episode
to watness to watch to witness
whatness to whatnot
[Laughter]
mary jane watson
uh but no i think the
yeah kind of how you were saying that i
felt like
i don't know if this is recency bias but
out of the seasons we've watched i feel
like this is the first time we're like
oh this is like
they really felt like a family there to
celebrate one another they're just
hanging out they're just having a good
time and i'm like you don't get that
with them yeah
you really don't
also a scene i really enjoyed was uh
lila and hargrave's finally meeting and
then kind of bonding together fantastic
that was a very sweet very cool scene
heart grapes is very suave very educated
man alien yeah supposedly someone who
doesn't have any people skills can
suddenly activate it like the best of
the best
and yeah i'm i'm really curious to know
how this is gonna turn around because
we're all very very drunk at the end of
this sweet moment and we know
this is umbrella academy so they're
gonna have to save the world so how is
that gonna come into play
um there's
you know there's always some sort of
twist always something
around the corner that we're not seeing
which which is that's the entry of the
show because even in the midst of this
very sweet very
wholesome episode we do get a little
glimpse of what is to come because
seemingly when you when you have
characters that accept the apocalypse
you would think that's like okay this is
going to be it but
uh yeah we got two more episodes so yeah
who knows who knows what's going on i
did like that they humanized um
uh ben significantly more 100 100 i
don't really know why he's got the anger
issues does they haven't given us that
yet uh but uh they teased something with
the the jennifer thing and they
referenced the the jennifer incident
which was the day he died but in this
alternate timeline seemingly she's the
one who died probably hardened they're
alluding to it without actually giving
it to us the
who's the actor plays klaus he's like
scottish in real life or something right
yeah robert
sheen
something like that he's just so
charming he's he's phenomenal he really
is just
he brings
it it is it is such a lived-in
performance
yeah brings all the shades of that
character to life every bit of it the
compassion the pain the sorrow the joy
and the humor
full spectrum yeah he's phenomenal and
on top of that too like you watch an
interview with the guy he's got like a
full-on scottish accent and you're like
damn would have never thought that from
watching you an umbrella academy um like
i thought for sure that that's just how
he
sounds that's how he talks that's that's
exactly how i thought he would talk
and then when i because i didn't i don't
think i saw an interview so after we
were done watching season two and then
when i saw an interview shocked because
i could have sworn he was just
he that would that had to at least have
been close to his actual voice but he
doesn't behave like this at all really
no he's got irish irish not scottish
okay yeah irish um but yeah he doesn't
behave like this
it's like nothing like doesn't behave
like clouds
it's it's kind of it's crazy just how
how how how much he brings to this
performance and um you know and i like
how
i think the the main easy way to sum up
this episode is it's just it's
full-blown display of the heart and uh
i kind of wish the first half of this
season felt a little bit more like the
last half of the season not gonna lie
because this season was starting to
worry me but
uh no that i do think that lately it's
been pretty freaking great and i'm just
hoping the final episode sticks the
landing but as it stands i'm looking
forward to it thank you all who have
been patient with us on our journey
some of you guys i just love i love when
i see the comments of people who comment
because like we shot like four or five
of these before we start uploading them
and then uh you know people will um
uh
people will comment as if
we should already know what the end of
the season right yeah like give us
a break
give us some time
we're not binging it guys
yeah
it's like no you don't get it dude i'm
like well now i get that comment because
i'm at this point in this series
we're not psychics
um but yeah ben definitely got better
all right guys thanks for being here and
uh
yeah i guess
but bye